balto huit mois a été chanceux il a été
adopté rapidement et y sommes
adoré son nouveau maître ils seront
abandonnées et on voulait absolument fan
est parti puis on a besoin un chien est
un animal dans notre vie pour ram nous
amener de l'amour au refuge zen à laval
c'est une année record
environ 80 bêtes abandonnées et les
propriétaires doivent même en refuser on
a à peu près une quarantaine de choc
présentement
puis on ne peut être une vingtaine de
chiens en refuge aussi et on a à peu
près sept familles d'accueil qui ont des
chapes à la maison des sharks ans 1 la
situation est aussi difficile à la
spéciale de montréal depuis un mois une
cinquantaine d'animaux ils sont laissés
tous les jours on veut garder autour
d'eux tenait du très bas on était autour
de 10% on veut pas été nazi des animaux
par manque d espace
on veut pas utiliser des animaux bonne
santé le taux d'occupation est de 75% à
la spc à de montréal ils mentent déjà
des places pour les oiseaux et les
lapins on a plusieurs cas de gens qui
n'utilisent pas trouvé de logement
qu'elle se plurent animal de personnes
âgées aussi qui partent en ch à celle
des acquis les services et des accès
pour les animaux les propriétaires de
logements ont le droit de refuser les
animaux selon un sondage réalisé par la
corpiq la corporation des propriétaires
immobiliers du québec
71 % des propriétaires de logements
accepte les chats ni seulement 24%
les chiens déchets qui ne jappe jamais
quand le maître et l'homme et lorsqu'ils
quittent le chien aboie toute la journée
dans le son des crêtes et comme les
délais sont très long à la régie du
logement avant d'obtenir une ordonnance
cela peut prendre de six mois deux fois
1 1 alors les propriétaires préfèrent
prévenir que guérir
les refuges pour animaux souhaite
maintenant que leurs nouveaux
pensionnaires soit adopté rapidement
pour donner de répit à leur personnel et
perdre la place aux nouvelles petites
bêtes qui sont en attente
il s'y garer bastien radio canada
montréal